when you land
the quarantine process immediately
begins
they spray down all your bags you have
to take a quarantine taxi
specifically designated to take you from
where you're going to your quarantine
i got to this hotel and we went down
into like
the uh the cargo entrance and in it is
this like screen
with like a person on the other side of
a webcam and
they just basically told me like take
that elevator don't touch anything
and it will like program it to go up to
your floor
this is ed i wanted to talk to him
because in 2020
he was one of more than half a million
people who went through a mandatory
two-week quarantine and then walked out
into taiwan
ed has dual citizenship in taiwan and
canada
but he lives in new york i do too
and for most of 2020 in new york the
streets
were empty venues were closed
but taiwan was normal
it's as if the pandemic had never
happened you could
go into restaurants subway
civil society had essentially stayed
exactly the same through all of 2020
taiwan had a total of seven covet 19
deaths
seven among the lowest in the world
[Music]
and then in may of 2021
something changed taiwan
is now experiencing rising daily
infections
huge surge largest wave taiwan is now
grappling with its worst outbreak
after more than a year of normalcy
taiwan faced its biggest
covet outbreak ever so
i wanted to understand how did taiwan
stay so safe from covet 19
for so long why did it stop working
and what can we learn from it
through the streets of taipei a major
parade symbolic of the fighting spirit
of nationalist china's army
in the fortress island taiwan started
out relatively poor and
under a military dictatorship but by the
1990s it had become a democracy and was
experiencing an
economic boom the government developed
the national health insurance system
which provided universal healthcare to
99
of the population this put taiwan on par
with wealthy countries around the world
well other than the us in 2001
they began to implement smart cards that
stored patients medical information
digitally that combination of universal
healthcare
and the digital infrastructure would
come to be regarded as one of the best
healthcare systems
in the world
then in 2003 china began reporting an
outbreak of severe
acute respiratory syndrome by march 2003
sars was in taiwan cases started rapidly
appearing in hospitals primarily in
taipei
in april a large cluster of cases was
reported at this hospital
in response the mayor of taipei abruptly
decided to seal the hospital
off preventing anyone from entering or
leaving more than 150 people trapped
inside
became infected of the more than 80
people who eventually died of stars in
taiwan
31 had been locked in that hospital
the government's response to sars was
chaotic
to handle the logistics of the outbreak
they'd set up a temporary agency called
the central epidemic command center
but when it came time to figure out who
had been
responsible for locking down the
hospital officials
at all levels of government disagreed on
whose decision
it had actually been we've had a lot of
problems
of say the municipal government saying
one thing and the central government's
saying anata
so in 2004 the role of the cecc
was clarified when activated during an
outbreak
this agency would now become the central
public health
authority with access to information
across government agencies
we've got a lot of public infrastructure
that's made like lego blocks
where people can very easily recombine
it to produce new functionalities
over the next 15 years the cecc was
activated during three smaller outbreaks
but the real test was yet to come
on december 31 2019 taiwan's government
learned that at least seven
atypical pneumonia cases had been
reported in wuhan
china and on january 20th they
officially activated the cec
because the cec could share information
across agencies
it was able to integrate citizens travel
data with their health data
together that combination allowed them
to assess risk
at the level of the individual people
who had recently traveled to countries
where they could have been exposed
were considered high risk people with no
underlying health issues who hadn't
traveled abroad were considered
low risk everyone in taiwan had that
information
sent to their smart card altogether it
created a system that looked something
like this
low-risk people were instructed to buy a
weekly quota of mosques allocated by the
government
but they'd continue to live in a
functional normal society
high-risk people went into a two-week
quarantine
after which they'd become low-risk and
could join
everyone else because of this taiwan
didn't have to go
into lockdown community spread among
people in taiwan
was very very low but in march
cases coming into taiwan began to rise
so taiwan came up with an additional
strategy
it started considering everyone flying
in to be high risk
no matter where they were coming from
and most foreign travelers were banned
completely that meant a lot more
mandatory quarantine
to enforce this the cecc used cell phone
location data to see if any travelers
left their quarantine block
the moment you close the door you see on
the back end there's like this huge red
scary sign that says you're going to be
fined a lot of money if you leave your
quarantine
you would get texts from the
neighborhood
police officer whose job it is to call
and check in on you
every single day actually twice a day
for two weeks the only human contact it
had was
through a peephole when someone came to
drop off food or
collect his trash
but then he got to join the nearly 24
million people in taiwan
living normal lives
this was an alternate universe of
what america and the rest of the world
had seen all year the
taiwanese people have been able to just
live their lives
as if nothing had happened like to me
that's freedom
when i started making this video it was
a story about how taiwan managed to beat
covet
but in may of 2021 a new wave of cases
suddenly put taiwan's success in
question
the total number of cases has actually
doubled more shops are going to be
forced to close
do not be complacent in the face of a
pandemic the lesson learned for
taiwanese
taiwan had gradually loosened its
quarantine system
which meant incoming infections started
to go
unchecked as of this video taiwan is
still getting its outbreak
under control thousands of people have
been sent through new rounds of
quarantine
but even taiwan won't be truly safe
until the system it built to keep the
pandemic out
is no longer necessary and the best way
we know of to get there
is to vaccinate on the flip side
after a very hard year new york looks
kind of normal again but it's not
because we finally figured out how to
contain covid
it's because of the vaccine this will
happen again
and we can't just be like oh well you
know there was a vaccine so it's all
good
at the end of all this even once we're
all vaccinated and
going to parties again we should look at
what did taiwan do right so that
we don't have to have the same
conversation in the future
because it is coming for more than a
year taiwan
stayed safe and free during a deadly
pandemic
but in a fight against a pandemic
mistakes are going to happen
the trick is to learn from them
you